hey man it's me kevin smith have you
been looking for all my old podcasts the
ones i started recording back in 2007
well guess what i found them
they're all hiding in that kevin smith
club all that shit's not exclusive
enough we got three more shows that are
only going to be going on at that kevin
smith club the return
of plus one the marital podcast that i
did with jennifer for years wake and
bake
with kev that's right a video show where
every morning whatever i'm doing while
i'm smoking man you're gonna hang out
with me
and then of course the exclusive kev
cast man that's the podcast of me just
by myself
or i just kind of do my own self therapy
while you listen
see all the video you've never seen
including exclusive movies and
live shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making
pins and miniature versions of my old
scripts if you want to be involved in
the least exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club now's your chance
to club kevin smith
[Applause]
[Music]
hey holy crap you caught me putting up
the uh
instagram story for what we're about to
do
and what we're about to do is gather
for fat man beyond welcome to fat man
beyond kevin smith
i am mark bernardin hey hello
kids welcome back to the show how's it
going everybody
now before i forget uh
do me a favor download hi-ho
map you can put it on your phone looks
like this
um what we're gonna do is uh we're gonna
try something out tonight like people
are always like i want to be on the show
so we're gonna pose a question
um and i'm gonna i'm gonna put it on
hi-ho and then
everyone could go there and respond to
it and then we're gonna
pull the best responses and at the end
of the show
run them that's [ __ ] fun so i've
never done this before
let's do it together um this is me
recording a hi-ho video
we get a good angle here okay make sure
nobody can steal your credit card
numbers from
the cards in the back of your phone
man well done yeah
this is me doing my high hope uh what's
the high hole question we should pose to
the audience
it should be about winter soldier i
would think so
so what is the um give us your favorite
moment of winter soldier
yeah yeah that's a good one okay here we
go
hey man it's me kevin smith we're
literally doing fat man beyond as we
speak and me and mark bernard came up
with a question from my initial hi-ho
uh leave your answers here your
responses we're gonna pull the best of
them we're gonna put them up
on the end of the fat man beyond show
tonight so here's the question
kids what's your favorite moment from
falcon and the winter soldier let me
hear it
all right now it says next i'll press
this
hey man kevin smith we're literally
doing me up
press this enter conversation
uh best moment [ __ ] winter soldier
best moment
i should download this app and
well done yeah here we go totally
prepared
the winter
whole audience is like can't you do this
[ __ ] before the show gets started
best moment in falcon in the winter
soldier
um it says oh you could do different
five minute limit
five minute rep i'm gonna put one minute
reply limit
smirt yeah right
um okay all videos posted on hi-ho are
viewable by the public
so careful kids please turn on
notifications
not now oh thank you
the hi-ho has been high headed
well done ladies and gentlemen so go to
hiho.com
or go to iowa it's an app you download
and you can answer that question
and we'll pull the best responses and
then we'll be able to put them on
to the show if this works we could do it
every week how do they find you in the
hi-ho app
how do they find me i am that kevin
smith same name as in twitter thank you
for pointing that out
and instagram that kevin smith morocco
okay we don't get to do this show
unless somebody says here's some
filthy lucra do the show um somebody got
paid these bills kids
certainly not funny hats doing it um
this week
uh our sponsor a proud sponsor fat man
beyond
are the good folks at keeps
you know we're talking about we've been
talking about keeps for months man
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
fat man k-e-e-p-s dot com
fat man to receive the first month of
treatment
free man that's keeps k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash fat man
to get your first first first first
month free kids keeps k-e-p-k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man mark
tell them what they're keeping what are
you keeping you're keeping your hair two
out of three men will experience some
form of hair loss
by the term they're 35 and what that
means like more than 50 million men in
america suffered from
male pattern baldness and they're only
two fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss
keeps offers both simple stress-free way
to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door
every three months you don't have to
leave your house low cost treatment
started like 10 bucks a month
and keeps offers generic versions as
well discrete packaging
results but with five star reviews than
any of its competitors
prevention is key boys treatment can
take four to six months to see results
so act fast
had i had keeps back in the day i
wouldn't be wearing funny animal hats
ladies and gentlemen
i've been rocking a lion's maid of hair
don't
necessarily make the mistakes that i
made in life because keeps didn't exist
back then when i was uh first
approaching
hair loss and stuff keeps your damn hair
man if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
fat man to receive your first month of
treatment for free man that's
keeps k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
to get your first month free keeps
ke keeps don't weeps
keeps look at that man he just wrote a
new slogan tagline for him
we thank the good folks at keeps don't
weeps uh as mark says
for uh sponsoring tonight's episode
of fat men beyond uh we have no guests
tonight kids
which is okay because we got a heart out
at six o'clock mark's got to do some
stuff
we're gonna be a plus he's got something
to do man and uh tomorrow we could have
done the show tomorrow but tomorrow
is my 22nd wedding anniversary oh yay
that's right so um what are you in the
mrs gonna do
oh [ __ ]
i thought we were still under quarantine
i thought i didn't have to do [ __ ]
uh we don't have anything planned um we
just came from a
weekend in new york and stuff last
weekend and we got
uh some travel coming up in the next few
weeks so i think
we'll be laying low maybe we'll take a
ride down the pch i've been threatening
to do that for like [ __ ] 20 years
one day we're gonna ride down the pch
still never did it i hear they got a
beach over there
i guess that's why i'm not into it i
grew up next to a beach in new jersey
and stuff
and some people are like yeah but that's
[ __ ] not the pacific i'm like you're
right
it's the atlantic what's your [ __ ]
point
water water everywhere not a damn job to
drink but um
i maybe will do that tomorrow i'll tell
you one thing for sure hopefully sex is
on the menu
it's how you get to 22 years she just
had a birthday
last week two weeks ago a few weeks ago
two weeks ago so she just turned uh
50 like like me and she's not one of
those women that's like
who could tell people i'm 26 she's like
[ __ ] 50. she's like i hated my 40s
i'm gonna love my
[ __ ] 50s so this is the first
anniversary mark first time in my life
i'm gonna [ __ ] me a 50 year old
and never go back
speaking of never go back kids we got uh
me and mark here we got a cartoon
that's coming up fairly soon this this
here year we do
masters of the universe colon revelation
man it's on its way
so naturally um you know it's
an easy gift to get kev is a
motu themed gift and people have been
sending them
like crazy so i wanted to share some of
the two of the things i got with you
because they're [ __ ] dope okay i'm
gonna get the box
okay this
is this gorgeous sculpture by
holy [ __ ] yes the artist's name is
madsky
now um he's got a really interesting
story man this cat
learned to speak english in bergen
county new jersey
while watching masters
of the universe where had he come from
that he didn't speak english
what a great question i know you're
going to ask me that and i'm like god
damn it i bet you i didn't hold that
hold on i'ma pull it up and
and read it to you because i just had it
where was it
how mad ski this is from hypebeast
who recently wrote uh us up for not us
but uh uh jay and sam bob for the
hundreds dropped their
kevin smith line this week and it sold
the [ __ ] out
in 36 hours so hypebeast did an article
on on that and i felt very
young and vital mark i was like i'm on
peace for heaven's sakes this is a
hypebeast piece from september 8th
2020 how madsky overcame racial
discrimination
by watching he-man the japanese artist
reflects
on traumatic childhood experiences for a
new solo show
at uh kai kai kiki gallery so um
in this piece let's see the year was
1980 madsky was six years old that had
just relocated from osaka japan
to bergen county new jersey with no
english skills whatsoever
strangers mocked him with racist taunts
and while his classmates were friendly
he still couldn't fully blend in feeling
a thick wall between them so instead of
playing with friends after school
mark he often ended up watching cartoons
at home alone
he was particularly obsessed with he-man
the masters universe an animated series
based on mattel's
masters of the universe line um in other
words he-man built a bridge
for the artist between two cultures
fundamentally shaping the core of his
personality
1984 was the year uh madsaki that's at
mensah
mastered english 1984 was also the year
masters of the universe had reached the
peak
of its boom so he did a show uh
the show's title was 1984 and
um he did a bunch of pieces so
this says uh the works
go on display will feature large-scale
paintings and sculptures of characters
from messes universe
such as enlarged action figures
alongside pieces
that depict an awkward ten-year-old
medsaki
and the exhibition ran from september to
october so
they released i guess a line of stuff
this is
the madsaki
piece oh damn so it's giant battle cat
and you know you can see well the he-man
comes off
i lost the sword so you can see he's
kind of
like painted differently and stuff the
dark kids this is what art looks like
um and the battle cat he's got like his
eyes are a little
runny and stuff um gorgeous
gorgeous piece bright very bright
indeed uh there's a place of honor
it's going up in on the shelf
you put him in the saddle when it goes
right in his crotch
um this will be going up on the shelf
right outside this here door that you
can't see
oh [ __ ] look at that there and we're the
sort of power drill
there it is uh okay
this is the other piece i wanted to show
you this came
i think they're both from mattel
creations this is
a mattel creations exclusive kit
[Music]
and that in that box was
this
oh no gun skeletor
that's [ __ ] badass you know what i'm
saying
so
that's him on the back of the box
gorgeous box artwork again it's from
mattel creations um the same guy
who designed this
is designing the action figures for the
revelation line
this is the actual piece
it is a you know for those of us who
grew up in the 70s and 80s
uh they had these giant look like this
called shogun warriors and they shot
their fists and stuff like that
guess what this guy does
he's got a havoc staff that also fires
march
nice he rolls right out kids pour his
other missiles down here and stuff
it is gorgeous
man look at this [ __ ] skeletor
shogun warrior um from the good folks
at mattel creation don't fall
uh let me tell you the guy's name who
who did that
because like i said he's doing our
action figures
um there it is
[Music]
ruben martinez reuben is the lead
designer
of uh motu toys at mattel great artist
they said
um group mattel creations their whole
group designed the
that the shogun warrior skeletor
um and reuben is part of that group man
and he's also designing the revelation
toys and stuff
how gorgeous that's amazing
i want one man like that is nuts ugh
in any event that's it for my show and
tell i've had that
here for like a couple weeks and i kept
wanting to show it but we got busy and
stuff
um you know i
i never got a shogun warrior when i was
a kid mark oh no
we were not a wealthy people you're not
a shogun family
my cousin had the godzilla which also
mysteriously shot its fist for some
reason yeah and you had a missile
yeah up in the tongue the leather tongue
there
but uh now i got one see it proves kids
if you just wait long enough
you'll get a shogun word everyone gets a
shogun warrior
you get a show no more you get a sugar
award you're the oprah of the shogun
warriors
uh on your uh instagram
or was it dark horse's instagram
somebody's instagram then there's a
master universe revelations comic book
there is the good folks at dark horse
have picked up the motu license like dc
had it for years they were doing comics
there
so now they're going to be doing all
their comics at uh dark horse
and uh a couple months ago they were
like hey do you want to do a
comic that ties in to revelation we were
like hell yeah because they you know
particularly they were like we'd give
mike mignola to do a cover we were like
um yes so um it
uh came together rather quickly me and
rob uh
david who is my boss at mattel and he
wrote he-man comics
most mo to comics at tc for a long time
he's exact
in charge of our our uh series
he's a head of mattel television i
believe
um him and i broke the story
and then um you know he was like let's
write this together i was like [ __ ] yeah
and we came up with the story and he's
like um
all right who's so you're gonna go write
it and i was like no i'll write half you
write half
he's like i don't have time to write
half i was like well i ain't doing this
whole thing by myself
and so we brought tim in tim sheridan is
also one of the writers
on our show wonderful writer he's uh you
know adapted the long halloween that's
coming
to home video and stuff from the dc
folks
uh tim uh took the scripting duties
uh uh for the series and stuff and uh it
ties in with
the orlax which is a creature that if
you had
castle grayskull the toy set there was a
sticker of a many tentacled creature in
the
dungeon as the orlax the story kind of
focuses on
on the orlax and it gives us a chance to
kind of like bring people up to speed
with like hey remember who all these
characters are
and it is a truly a prequel to the story
that we tell
in revelation so yeah i think that's
coming when did they say it's like june
or july or something
i think so i didn't i didn't i didn't
read too i didn't i just saw the cover
i didn't click through to the to the
news stories but i was just
dazzled by the mcneola color cover it's
like i like maniola
i know prince harry so so damn nice
yeah man it's uh i have the power mark
and it's happening soon
folks are gonna know no more i think
there's a first look coming up in a
couple weeks
i'll say no more good folks at netflix
are very
supportive of of uh the show and um you
know there's
i've seen plans
marketing plans they're putting some
might behind it both mattel and
netflix so yeah it's coming
i got uh the good folks at geeky jersey
sent me uh
i don't know if you can see it it's a
skeletor jersey
they make you know a couple they make
all sorts of themed jerseys but this one
is
cool the lords of destruction um
yeah man that's the if you're like how
do i get kev
this year for birthday christmas motu
seems to be the easy go-to
motu's your go-to yeah
what you got going on uh now this week
has been
um putting some stuff to bed
which is nice you know like documents i
gotta get filed are being filed and
clearing the decks a little bit
new work is coming together which is
very exciting you know
naturally i can't talk about any of it
um
but uh welcome to the circumspect show
kids
yeah i'm doing a cool thing we just
can't tell you [ __ ] we talk about
everyone else's projects we can't talk
about our own
um but yeah i think in the beginning of
the week i think started on a very
strong note in that i we got a shang chi
trailer which did not expect to get it
dropped in the most adorable way
which is the lead actors uh scene with
lou's birthday
mark was like hey man happy birthday
here's a teaser for your movie
um we all got a birthday gift we did
indeed
and uh it's kind of beautiful like i
didn't i had no expectations for this
movie at all i i knew
a very little context for shang chi like
i remember the books but wasn't a big
reader of them
um but yeah this feels
this feels like a legit movie that you
know is telling a new kind of story
within them the mcu
it feels like marvel doing martial arts
yeah
i mean it's it's legit mcu wusha you
know
these old school chinese you know
martial arts operas
and like as much as it's an urban story
about this kid who had been trained to
be
you know the greatest martial arts in
the world um and then his father gave
him 10 years to to go out into the world
and live your life before
responsibility would come calling again
and
flashbacks to what seemed to be these
grand
sort of operatic martial arts sequences
and
horseback stuff and armies against
walled cities and
and then you get bus rides with aquafina
like
it looks kind of great it was
um for those that don't know the books
very well
shang chi in the comics 70s
master of kung fu was this marvel book
kung fu the tv series was just about to
break on tv
so marvel picked up the license to do
books at the same time they were like oh
let's let's tie it in with something
you know else something bigger it's
comics like you know let's blend it
so they have the rights to foo manchu
a problematic uh character that's been
around for i don't know
67 years or whatever um
and so in the comics shang chi
is the son of the great fu manchu
and you know he wanted his son to follow
in his footsteps but the son would never
do it fought against and and the book
was kind of like
an asian like fusion or
james bond martial arts james bond
cotton not very different from
you know batman's son of the dru or soul
of the dragon or whatever the
recent dc piece that they did
so um you know they've in the in the
trailer
aside from uh shang chi himself who's
the main character as mark said the son
who was given ten years a kind of
rumsbricka of sorts
like go out and sow your wild oats then
come back and
rule the world by my side for the
purposes of
of the marvel cinematic universe and
probably even in the comics at this
point i haven't read them in ages
um they've changed it from fu manchu to
the mandarin
now the mandarin is also a character who
can be considered problematic
um that marvel has had around for years
and years and years and iron man foe was
originally supposed to be the bad guy
in the first iron man movie until
favreau and foggy were like
this might be a bit too you know racy
and so
they left him until iron man 3 when they
did the other version with trevor
slattery the guy who at first seemed
like a terrorist but instead was like a
british actor
and in one of their marvel shorts that
they put on like the dvd years ago
they did a little you know short of of
trevor slattery going to jail
and and [ __ ] somebody being like the
real mandarin wants to talk to you
and that was the last thing they ever
did and then when they announced shang
chi
they announced that the mandarin was
going to be the main character and that
he in fact
is going to be retconned as shang chi's
dad
um and you know like [ __ ] the 10
rings is part of it
in the comics the mandarin has like 10
rings that literally have powers on his
fingers
in this incarnation it looks like he has
powered hands
rings around his arms so nothing rings
but rings
um it looks great i mean i don't want to
raise something up or lower something
else to raise something else up but like
you know last time
anything marvel went near anything
martial arts it was iron fist and
that did not look like this look now
let's be fair
iron fist had you know bucco 5 per
episode as a budget whereas this has
all the disney money in the world and
stuff so
you know we're seeing amazing as mark
said
mass fighting shots with what look like
stone
dog lions coming to life and joining the
fight and stuff
uh looks spellbinding
so um i'm shocked we got this trailer
before we got the the eternals but
i was happy to get anything it was nice
to see marvel something
marvel new for the movie theater like
something like oh [ __ ] that's right we
are going to go back
yeah why aren't we and also like it
doesn't look like any other marvel we've
seen
so far yeah i mean it's always exciting
when they
they sort of elbow their way into an
arena that they haven't been before
and see what they bring to it you know
and then it'll be really interesting to
see how this will then sort of dovetail
in with the rest of the sort of mainline
mcu
in the same way that there was no way to
know how guardians would eventually come
into play in
in in the main storyline but then when
you get it it makes all the sense in the
world and it's this
it's the s'mores of entertainment and so
i can't wait to see how this and
eternals plays into doctor strange too
plays into spider-man like you know
where
because we no longer have that thanos is
coming
magnet it'll just be we're still in the
new phase
and then the beginnings of what's going
to be the next big move for marvel and
so
galactus galactus
fingers crossed um yeah it looks
phenomenal
but it also means that we're probably
gonna get a eternals trailer pretty soon
yeah within the next month i would think
you know probably if i had to guess
it might be a little late for it to be
attached to black widow
but black widow's july and eternals is
december november i think and that that
timing would kind of work out
what's the name of the star um simulu
s-i-m-u-l-i-u uh he's gonna be so famous
probably famous right now but he's gonna
be so [ __ ] famous
and like just the shot in the [ __ ]
what looks like the either the bus or
the train where he [ __ ] just like
punches the two dudes and then like hops
up and kicks them both in the face
yeah i mean you know i i know i'm like
[ __ ]
ignorant but like that looks like it was
done with no special effects
that looked that's just a dude that's
what i'm saying that just looks like a
dude kicking somebody in this insane way
um so that yeah that looks kind of
magical i look forward as [ __ ] to them
as do i and it was it was a it was a
nice warm up a nice sort of uh
aperitif tuning up for the falcon winter
soldier finale
um what a great segue let's talk about
it kids get ready to punch
this time code in at youtube
talk about somebody got on my dick on
twitter this week they're like
leave that guy alone he helps us out
those of you who're doing a service
he did that's what they said he's like
we can't all watch your whole show i'm
like
well [ __ ] you but he's they pointed out
they're like that's a good thing he does
that we weren't saying it's a bad thing
we're just making fun of it
that being said mark the time
kids because now all the chatter of
falcon and the winter soldier begins we
saw the final episode
what started as the falcon in the winter
soldier and ended
as captain america in the winter soldier
we got to see the debut
of sam in the captain america costume we
got to hear sam
call himself captain america which
somebody was like i thought captain
america was on the moon
which is like that's that's a that's a
teaser for something like that theory
right is that steve rogers is
like you know because people like what
happened to him after you know the
events of endgame and [ __ ] like that
and there's a theory that he's him and
peggy carter have been on the moon
with you know uh what's his name [ __ ]
nick fury
like so i thought it was funny that
somebody actually said i thought he was
on the i thought captain america was on
the moon
um historic debut
of uh captain america sam
uh wilson playing captain america being
captain america
picking up the shield even though you
know they [ __ ] bloodied that shield
two weeks ago and then literally had
isaiah bradley say
they will never let a black man be
captain america
even though you know i'm i work in this
business
and i should you know should have damn
well known of course that
everything was going to work out there
were a couple episodes episodes four and
five where i was like
i don't think i think they're gonna get
rid of captain america i think they're
just gonna let it go
like but they pulled it back they had
sam kind of redeem it for his own
personal reasons what did you think
about the rationale that he gave to the
press
um you know i
it's it's weird like that that speech
that sam gives
you know sort of dressing down the grc
brass and
the assorted senators and bankers and
whoever makes that up like the
basically the star chamber um
you know is both like stirring
and a little bit all over the place and
doing a sort of a lot of heavy lifting
to help
underscore things that weren't
dramatized in the way you hoped they
would
be um and yet you know
the the speech that he gives to to
isaiah i think is a little bit more on
point about that where he says you know
our people have we built this country
we've bled for this country
nobody's gonna tell me that i can't
fight for it you know
and i think that's that's the sort of
the sum up of his refutation of the idea
that you know they're never gonna let
you be captain america you know i
i did sort of want the scene where
the senator or somebody or anybody in
authority is like
you can't carry that shield and he says
come and take it from me you know or
whatever you know the
you wanted that sense that like is there
a friction there between the government
and him
is there some some culpability for him
essentially taking the shield from there
captain america and wearing it
and wielding it um but i think it's it's
you know
so much of what worked for me in this
finale was the isaiah bradley stuff
and you know and you called it like a
lot of people would be giving me credit
for it but no you were the dude who
called
we did that yeah that scene like [ __ ]
him uh
bringing him in believe me as it started
to happen i was like no
no and it's everything i wanted it was
beautiful and
the the performance um god what is the
name of the actor replacement
carl lumley's performance when he goes
in for the hug
with sam is is honestly one of
uh the most breathtaking performance
beats in
any marvel anything you feel
the appreciative weight of the world on
the man's shoulders
as his as he said like in episode what
three or whatever
like they erased me they erased my my
whole life
and there he is on a race there he is on
display
profoundly beautiful watching him shake
sam's embrace you know like i there was
a moment
where i didn't know how he was
necessarily going to react
when he first saw it like what if he was
just like you know
isaiah stayed on brand he was like the
hell with all this [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] your
statues
exactly exactly and i was like what a
weird way to end it
sam's all like happy and self-satisfied
i did this for you and he's like [ __ ]
your stash
thankfully he didn't thankfully he
created like a very moving response and
[ __ ]
um that was it was a great scene they
could have ended the show there and then
they gave us a nice little
down on the bayou kind of wrap up and
stuff like here's uncle buck
yes of uncle buck
uncle sam and uncle buck um
let's go back to the top though sam
debuts
in the uh the captain america suit yeah
courtesy of the wakandans looks very
similar to the one in the comics
indeed a little a little puffy from from
my uh
for my look what was that all about you
think because he's a really thin dude
but i did think it was
not and not like this ruined it but i it
was a little puffy what do you think
that was about
i don't know i mean because it's it's
very comic book accurate very comic book
you know
sort of like it's it's on the money but
in real life like it's a little like
stay puft marshmallow cat
it's happening because like the
shoulders are puffy and like there's
ridges where you're like why isn't this
kind of sleek marshmallow cat
you know why maybe maybe did anybody
tell them nobody should wear white after
labor day but
like it's not slimming dude wait you're
not kidding bro
i'm not i was literally watching the
show going like
connie looks so trim when he's falcon
why does he not and it's because he's
just wearing this
white outfit you're right
um but yeah and and you know him [ __ ]
owning it
you know him walking in and people like
you know who the hell are you like i'm
captain america
right yeah that's a pretty [ __ ]
badass and when bucky called him cap
he's like nice job capping yeah
the opening of course gives us the intro
of the outfit but also
we get to see the outfit in action sam
fighting with the shield
while using wings and his jet pack and
stuff
uh one of the coolest beats was when he
was fighting
uh car wasn't carly carly carly
morgenthau at one point like his [ __ ]
wings
came out and and jutted into the ground
to brace him
so he's holding the shield up front and
the wings are like
creating an anchor against that was so
[ __ ] dope and then of course
the other great moment was when he pulls
the guy out of the helicopter like red
wing pulls one guy out he pulls the
other guy out
they land and then he [ __ ] domes them
up with the wings and the shield on top
and the [ __ ] helicopter
hits it and goes off and the whole
bridge like
yeah spider-man 2 where there's a lot of
people cheering for
very and then they had another one of
those moments later on where he's like
that's the black falcon he's like no
that's captain america right there
like really sweet um so we get to see
uh sam in action in the suit um as him
and bucky go in and try to save the
the grc the guy who played the senator i
was pretty sure it was somebody's like
uncle or or one of the marvel producers
cause like i was like this guy
so he just he seemed he seemed like a
friend
more than
but i but he's a legit actor i looked
him up in the thing and he's like he's
been in a bunch of things and stuff
it's like hey man i just i got to make
my sag minimum this year can you just
put me on screen
or somebody was like i've been working
on like honestly as i watched it the
first few times i was like
maybe that's louis desposito like the
guy who's in the credits all the time
what's his name louis
louie yeah the d esposito the esposito
who's like
one of the biggest muckety mucks at
marvel him and victoria and kevin feige
all work together
and in my mind i was like i think that's
i think that's that guy
he was just like i've been working on
these marvel movies forever i want to be
in one and they're like fine go ahead go
ahead
but oh it turns out and again it's not
because i'm like that guy was not a good
actor he was totally fine but it felt
like a part you could have given
a famous somebody you know what i'm
saying like somebody was like ooh
like that's like a robert redford part
in civil war
so this guy lucked out in a big bad way
yeah it's a bit like
you know when uh i think it's it's
anthony russo
is one of the guys in the beginning of
end game
um who's around the sort of like the the
aaa
the survivors group going on a date and
[ __ ] yeah and it's like oh look at that
good for you like you're an actor go out
there and act a bit
but yeah like that character you could
tell like he doesn't even have a name
he's just
senator he doesn't he's not even senator
in the credits it's just like
government guy or something because at
one point sam calls him senator so i was
like oh he must be senator
in the credits but he's not that um it's
it is the part that i think like
you know is the best chance i'd ever
have of being in a marvel movie
just the dude to talk behind a desk for
a bit dubious government official
you know who's just like you know
somebody
some one of the heroes has to be like
you listen to me senator you know at the
end put me in my place and [ __ ] like
that
yeah it's like you get three scenes you
get one scene where you dress somebody
down
you get another scene where you learn a
thing and then you get a final scene
where you tell somebody they did a good
job
yeah that's your arc that's what i want
man
um all right so uh we get
uh to see sam in action and then uh you
know there's
they spent that money on this episode
the helicopter sequence is
expensive and dazzling as sam tries to
rescue people
uh from a moving helicopter of course
you've got to have him do some [ __ ] in
the air at one point bucky's like
you know uh sharon carter shows up in
new york wearing a [ __ ]
mission impossible mask and uh you know
she's like you better hurry sam the
helicopter's taking off
and sam's like bucky and bucky's like
find your thing man that ain't me he's
trying to beat ass and [ __ ]
and then [ __ ]
john walker shows up with his homemade
shield
[ __ ] shield that he hurls and carly
morgenthau just kicks out of the air and
wobble wobble wobble tumbles to the
ground so sadly you see on the other
side it's like
leather and boss got some [ __ ] bling
on it and [ __ ]
uh but we forget that he's a super
soldier that's the thing that's
so impressive about sam as captain
america
he may have the wings but sam is not a
super soldier he even says it later on
he's like i have no super soldier serum
i got no blond hair no blue eyes
like he's just a dude in a suit he's
john walker at the beginning of this
show
like just a dude who's like you know i'm
wearing a captain america outfit but he
ain't got no powers
john walker now full of pump full of
super soldier serum
i like the idea of a captain america
without
the super soldier serum that's the case
yeah we can more identify with and [ __ ]
he's batman who's like with far less
trauma
yeah and far less [ __ ] emo and you
can talk to him he seems friendly
um i i i was not a fan
of reintroducing john walker in this
episode
um i thought they could have left him
out you could have you could have done
that the last time we see him is when
he's like dressed down by the military
and angry
and madame hydra handsome in the card we
see him building the shield
and then you the let the next thing he
never comes back never coming he comes
back to that [ __ ] courtroom sequence
when they're like
try it on the helmet fits and it's
clearly bad guy john walker is now us
agent
and you know what these scenes did is
like they rehabilitated him
suddenly he's like he's a member of the
team again
like nobody has any questions nobody's
like hey you just killed a dude last
time we saw you and we kicked your ass
for that
he did kill a flag smasher a terrorist
so you know that's probably how he gets
away with it but i
i too was like oh i'm shocked they're
gonna redeem him because i was assuming
they were heading him toward u.s agent
but
they're not just making him a bad guy
he's probably it looks like they're
building
the dark avengers you know to be honest
with you but um
he uh i loved you know him
pulling up the [ __ ] armored car like
he had the moment between
going to chase carly morgenthau and
saving
you know the grc inside the truck and
and he goes for like i'm a sucker for
that [ __ ] i got real weepy when
they you know move around the truck and
you see him pulling it back
and then he gets attacked so he [ __ ]
goes down it's all for naught and [ __ ]
but then
of course the truck is saved by sam
wings and all and stuff
like i just felt like that also could
have been bucky
you're right you're looking occupied
i was glad that they did re redeem him
like a little bit but you're absolutely
right story-wise they could have just
cut to his last scene and stuff but it
was nice to see them all fighting
together and [ __ ] like they just
he just wants a friend he lost his body
yeah he's a little nervous
you're like he should be alone and hang
you know what's really weird though is
like they had him lying
to lamar's family in the last episode
there ain't no closure on that
he just flat out [ __ ] lied and it's
like you know
here's your new suit credit and that's
it
yeah like right that's the dark avengers
because that [ __ ] is dark mark
yeah i mean like just the the ease and
speed
in which it just the show decided to
rehabilitate him
his image and his persona in the eyes of
the audience
was just a little less interesting for
me like having the dude who killed the
wrong guy and lied to the parents and
you know got bounced out of the military
and like what's his
engineer what's his impetus going
forward like that's a dark dude who
might be trying at some point to come
out of it and rehabilitate himself in
redemption
but this redemption was like way easy
like he shows up he helps a dude out
and it's like hey thanks buddy pat on
the back let's go punch some bad guys
you know joking as they walk off like
where's his reaction to sam holding the
shield
like where's the moment where like he
sees this [ __ ] captain america walk
up
i was like that should be me i want that
like you took my birthday they had the
moment where
uh captain america sam uncle sam
uh gives him the nod where he's like
you know yeah that could have been like
a lot hotter of a confrontation given
the last time they saw each other
um very true my uh from walter flanagan
uh i was texting with him last night
walter from comic book men
um he he watched the show and dug it as
well his big question was like who's the
guy that blew up
the van full of people i was like that's
emo's butler man
and walter is like oh that's a left down
he's going i thought that was meant to
be somebody cool
in episode three i was like it was cool
it just shows you that zemo no matter
where he is
he's pulling strings like they [ __ ]
you know he he's even he's on the raft
and he's still got those [ __ ] killed
and [ __ ]
uh but walter pointed this thing out so
you know uh
sam saves the grc vehicle
pushes it up and [ __ ] and then lands
down you know
on the ground and [ __ ] whips his
shield around and and knocks some
some super soldiers around and and carly
morgenthau and stuff and then they go
running and then he's uses goggles to be
like hey man they're in the [ __ ] in
the dusty tunnels or whatever the [ __ ]
and then uh carly morgenthau winds up
having a one-on-one
with sharon carter who yes it turns out
is the power broker
and three episodes ago it's like i bet
you she's the pair broker because who
else is it going to be
exactly uh so they have a kind of a
one-on-one and then patrock the leaper
comes in
and finds out that she's the [ __ ]
power broker
because she brought him in to [ __ ] with
who knows what's going on with sharon
carter and uh then
sam shows up and sam and carly fight and
he won't fight her
but she's trying to fight him and he's
more just defending
and then uh she gets the drop on sam and
she is gonna [ __ ] fire the gun but
instead sharon carter
draws down and shoots her after sharon
carter had been shot by
carly the leaper um
i thought she got shot and then what
they were gonna do
was like you know [ __ ] cut to later
on
like you see the bullet come out and she
heals up
and she was gonna be introduced as the
first mutant or whatever the [ __ ]
they had other plans for agent carter
though so uh but walter pointed out like
so in that scene
sharon carter shoots carly
morgenthau killing her and there's
sharon carter
with a gut shot bleeding
and sam this is what walter pointed out
he's like why the [ __ ] did
did sam do the funeral [ __ ] walk of
death
with carly morgenthau when his [ __ ]
friend
could use medical attention like why
didn't instead of like
picking her up and like bringing her to
the people and being like you people
suck
why wasn't he helping karen carter i was
like
i guess you got a point i couldn't find
that one
because literally it took harley and he
was like you're good right and she's
like
i'm [ __ ] shot in the stomach he's
like well i'll see you and he takes off
with
her yeah i gotta go make a speech we see
her yeah he's like i got a speech to
give
and then we see her later on with bucky
outside and [ __ ]
and then of course in the ps scene uh
post-credits sequence
uh you saw her get her name clear and
they're like welcome home agent carter
and then she gets outside and she's like
[ __ ] super soldiers we got access to
high-tech weaponry
essentially saying she gonna be a double
agent and stuff
i am still as a power broker and i'm now
open for business again
i don't know why suddenly she's like
german but
[ __ ] it really well done series
um you know completely different than
wand division
wasn't this kind of like uh you know
um capture the imagination of the world
and stuff
very straightforward you know action
show but
it's exceptionally made um
you know sad to see it end but it looks
like it's handing off
to as we saw in the press this week
captain america four malcolm it was
malcolm spellman
who did the series is gonna do the next
captain america movie and the next
captain america movie
is sam and that's captain america so it
looks like maybe that's what they'll be
doing instead of another season of
captain america in the winter soldier it
looks like they might just go do
captain america four yeah i mean i think
that their plans are always
you know playing it forward and kind of
handing off
and not nearly as conventional as let's
just do more seasons of this
like that idea of these stories bouncing
between tv shows and movies
and ping-ponging these characters sort
of to and fro
like maybe their next series out of this
is agent carter
you know and then what that story is
didn't they
didn't they already do agent carter was
it
that is a new agent card you fangled
agent carter i
am was not a big fan of the agent carter
twist i'll play with it i'll go with it
i'm not like i'm out but it's
it you know i'm hoping
that uh she comes to feature prominently
in secret invasion and perhaps we find
out that this sharon carter
was not sharing carter at all yeah
but a scroll i i i can retcon a lot of
[ __ ] with that storyline they go out and
[ __ ] scroll anybody in their universe
it's gonna be yeah
yeah i mean there's there's like there's
there's the surface coolness of it
but then there you run into this problem
of like
if if nobody is anybody then
dramatically what does any of this mean
well that was walter's point he's like i
thought the butler is going to be like
[ __ ] magneto and i'm like well let's
see it's cmos butler he's like that
ain't cool i'm like yeah
like if alfred [ __ ] blew up some [ __ ]
on batman's behalf
um yeah i mean i i i kind of i'm a
little torn
on this season of the show like i think
emotionally
it lands in all the right places you
know and at the end of the day like
that's that's why we
engage in serialized drama because we're
emotionally invested in it and so
if you're emotionally invested in sam
and bucky then they do
make their journey as characters um and
they do find
some sense of you know absolution and
some sense of completion
and a sense of progression and that's
that's kind of what you want
but like there's lots of things that
just didn't really make any sense like i
still don't know what carly's whole plan
was
you know or in a big way like why she
was doing what she's doing other than
i don't want to be repatriated could
have something to do with the fact that
uh
they you know we heard earlier reports
that there was a different
storyline a different season series
finale
that focused more on them like uh
releasing some germ warfare something
that
was a little uncomfortably close to
recent events
yeah so from what i understood they
changed paths
all together so maybe that [ __ ] with
her
arc or whatever totally possible like i
think the whole like
you know we're all meeting for the
funeral of a woman that we've never
established means anything in the show
but i have a feeling that
there was a viral version of this where
that character had been present and we
had gotten to meet her and we see what
she meant and we see what her death does
and how that radicalizes people but you
know by the time you get to the final
scene with
sam and carly and he's refusing to fight
her
i don't know why he is you know i mean
it's definitely a callback to when sam
when bucky and and steve went at it for
the first time
you know and it's like i'm not going to
fight you man like i'm with you to the
end of the line and but you understand
why he won't fight his best friend you
understand why you know absorbing that
much damage
to let bucky exercise his demons is
necessary
but for this i'm like dude just punch
her like she's a terrorist like
i get that you sympathize with her but
you've only ever had one scene with this
woman
in which you got to hear her point of
view why you're suddenly
you know ultimately at the end of it
doing her job for her
like in this movie in this series
terrorism wins
where like she kidnapped these people
she did bad stuff to her to them
she dies and then she gets what she
wants because sam convinces the
you know the grc to not do what they're
doing like
the villain plot came together
ultimately
and sam was the final key in that cog
um which is also not a saying but
you know what i was i was sitting there
going he's such a good writer he knows
[ __ ] i don't i'm so glad you were like
that's not a thing because that's not a
thing
that is a thing and i'm about to use it
on my wife on the show
i'm like nothing but a key in a cog
kind of old wild scale [ __ ] is that
yeah
um so yeah like i just i kind of wanted
that to make some more sense
you know i wanted and i wanted them to
be as protagonists an antagonist
a little bit more deeply intertwined or
at least philosophically
you know um at odds with each other but
you know like that's plot at the end of
the day you know but the resolution you
get between sam and bucky
the resolution you get between sam and
isaiah the resolution you get between
sam and his family and ultimately sam
and america
it does sort of trump the fact that like
yeah bad guy plan doesn't make that much
sense yeah
she's interesting but not that much
um isaiah's grandson going like what you
want black falcon
you need to learn
[Laughter]
like what is up your [ __ ] ass kid
really like ottoman [ __ ]
he's softened up by the time they went
to the museum and stuff but
every time he's like we going for a ride
like you taking me someplace did you buy
tickets
he turned on a dime instead of like what
do you want grizzly adams
all of a sudden he's like let's take a
ride you got a car holy [ __ ] we're
friends
yeah we going to wendy's can we stop at
wendy's that'd be great
that sequence though is uh worth the
trip alone
like yeah watching him walk into that
museum and
see that room and stuff like that like
and now hopefully you know look they
they
walk away with an embarrassment of
riches after this show
right because now they know for a fact
they can go make a [ __ ]
isaiah bradley series set in world war
ii or right in uh
[ __ ] the korean war and go over like
[ __ ] crazy
crazy absolutely they established
madripore
as the first beachhead and in the battle
of the mutants
as getting the mutants into the marvel
cinematic universe
uh zemo they extended and turned him
into a rich [ __ ] character and he was
pretty rich
from civil war to begin with man but
he's become fast become one of the
greatest marvel villains of all time
without even wearing the mask all the
time and chilling
um yeah bucky got a little bit of
closure
and [ __ ] hope and [ __ ] and they still
gotta
give him a better code name winter
soldier don't feel like
you know an avengers kind of name and he
can't call him bucky
and it's a little diminutive um
but yeah if they decide to make a
captain america the lost avenger
series you know like somebody and
somebody tagged me into a piece of art
on instagram
that was you know isaiah bradley looking
back over the shield
and it's like yeah [ __ ] give me a
season of that give me eight episodes
of that i'm here for it you know what
marvel let me do it
let me [ __ ] do it i'll tell you i
want it let me do that show
um walter also pointed out he's like man
they [ __ ]
had no problem killing people in that
show
but i don't think sam did sam didn't
kill anybody did he
no they they very carefully were like
that the flag smash he splashed into the
hudson is still alive
yes go get him okay anytime
captain america yeah he's like always
happy to help or whatever
oh yeah very um they're careful to make
sure that he don't
kill and i kind of appreciate that um
you know although i don't bump into it
you know like walter did where he's just
like they killed pretty easy i'm like
well they're terrorists like yeah the
terror they're bad guys and these are
soldiers
yeah super soldiers super [ __ ]
terrorists and [ __ ]
um but all in all like another
worthy entry uh into the marvel
cinematic universe canon man these
disney plush shows are
proving to be a boon for their
storytelling
yeah i mean now now it becomes a quilt
like now it becomes this big fabric this
vast canvas they get to work on
you know as opposed to every you know
every eight months we would get a marvel
movie
and now we can have you know 20 hours of
marvel content a year as opposed to four
um and i think that's for a fan this is
the best possible version of it
uh u.s agent him coming out in the black
suit that was dope
um the fact that they gave him the suit
that looks like the suit
the fact that she called him u.s agent
madame hydra
um they gave you know this this new show
gave us
her as well looks like she's going to be
sticking around like the
modern day nick fury now that he's up in
space
um he's he's coming soon too man with
his own series with secret invasion
indeed you know if we wanted to segue
right to the news
that's our first news item well let's do
it man hey kids don't forget
go to high hole right now tell us your
favorite uh go to my that kevin smith on
ohio
and tell us uh your favorite uh
moment of captain america and the winter
well the guy it is captain america's
electric soldier
and uh we'll pull them for the end of
the show and we'll put them up here so
you could see it
indeed okay but that's the review or the
recap
section of captain america and the
winter soldier hats off
to uh malcolm spellman to kevin feige
all the
folks that directed to to carry his
carries skogland i think her name i
corrected every episode
yeah she was the only one on the show so
um and she killed it like it's a
gorgeous show
yeah and it looks expensive as [ __ ] yeah
their cheap episodes looked expensive
you know well done to all involved i
look forward to
watching it again in a couple of months
however what's next for them is
is it uh loki it's loki yeah loki
in in june we get loki so we got a month
with no marvel and then it comes back
yeah
a month and a half we have you know half
of april and all of may
but we're getting the bad batch that's
what disney plus has put me up
yeah we'll get that in in in may if i
had to guess
time to may the fourth because they're
also not idiots
um and so we go from that to
um loki and then black widow
and then shang chi in august i believe
and then eternals yeah and then
spider-man
somewhere in there too and then doctor
strange too
it's all coming my friend i want it all
i want the world
yeah i want the whole world and then
we'll get moon night in there at some
point because i
you know we did see if not last week
then the week before some footage of
oscar isaac training for moon knight so
that ought to be
cheating like that dude's such a good
actor and when you see him put that much
effort into like a fight sequence you're
like
i'll never be that good at anything in
my life
um and don't forget we got hawkeye
mm-hmm
yeah hawkeye's wrapped so that should be
in post and that there's there's
absolutely a world in which that's uh by
like november december
great time to be alive kids a great time
to be alive if you're a marvel fan and
who the [ __ ] is it all right man there's
the review the recap if you will
indeed now we're heading over to the
news man mark
he knows news he's got a nose for news
man he's an old newshound
now he's a young writer pup but now uh
as he can merge his two worlds man
he's got foot in both worlds and for
this brief moment in time he holds open
the window to the past
and pretends he's a man of news as he
brings us
the weekly news mark what's the news um
well the the big story this week you
know which we already mentioned was
um captain america four which there's no
release date for
there's you know no other co-stars named
but malcolm spellman is co-writing it
with a fellow named delon musan who was
a staff writer on [ __ ] winter soldier
um but yeah man so that's coming there's
no director attached
and evan's involved evidences of
involvement or return remains
unconfirmed
um but secret invasion
um a show that is at the very least in
the writing process of not in the actual
production process you're casting like
crazy right casting like crazy
um oscar winner olivia coleman is in
talks to join
um you know sam jackson and ben
mendelsohn in secret invasion
um as is uh game of thrones star emilia
clarke who's also
in the cast kingsley benadir
is likely the villain and he was he
played malcolm x in um
one night in miami and he was great um
so yeah man they're they're rapidly
heating that up if not already deep into
production on it
who do you think amelia clark's gonna
play i don't know man
like i i i don't remember i mean i
remember reading secret invasion the
the sort of event you know at this point
now what is that like 15 years ago
um but i have i don't have a ton of
recall
as to who she could be or uh or what she
could be up to
in chat walrus union wrote a wrap at my
sister nell
but cap is on the moon
oh that's that's classic um all right
man what else we got
um into the spider verse 2 has revealed
its directors
um we knew that joaquin dos santos was
was already named as one of the
directors or the director
for the movie but they have since added
kemp powers
who is a current oscar nominee for um
co-directing
seoul from pixar as well as writing
um one night in miami um and justin k
thompson all three of them are directing
simultaneously and apparently have been
doing so since the beginning they just
didn't announce the other names
um phil lord and chris miller are now
also
um joining as screenwriters
for the spider-verse movie for the
spider-verse movie they're joining a
fellow named david
callahan who coincidentally wrote shanxi
and the legend of the ten rings
um so yes it seems as if they are they
are stocking this with
talent to make sure it's a worthy heir
to the first film
all this news is
making my heart race i think i requires
a
a puff of a clove cigarette
indeed you know celebrate yeah enjoy
yourself
clove it up um
my cloven hooves are are
satisfied don't smoke tobacco kids but
cloves
yeah um and justin k thompson um was the
production designer for the first end of
the spider-verse movie
um and so he is he's sort of getting the
bump up to co-director on this one
and peter ramsey who co-directed the
first one is still on as an executive
producer
you know along with lord and miller to
help the continuity
of uh of excellence so i can't [ __ ]
wait
um they you know you can't [ __ ] you
got
good marvel coming from disney you got
good marvel coming from [ __ ] sony
what more can you ask for you got some
good marvel coming on hulu man did you
see the modoc trailers
i did i did like th that's [ __ ] fun
don't it
from the stupid buddy folks um who made
um
um clone [ __ ] i can't remember the
name of that
clone eye no that was lord miller
um [ __ ] um no
seth green's oh robot robot chicken
there it is
i don't know where that where that came
from um
yes smoking them clove cigarettes marks
i you know it's getting in my head man
it's getting in my head um and speaking
of disney and
sony and hulu um disney and sony have
finally made a deal
that will bring all of the spider-man
movies to disney plus
so we can finally have the entirety of
the mcu on one platform again
yeah they made a big fat deal with sony
first uh the spider-man movies are going
to go to netflix as previously announced
a couple months ago
but then after that's done they come
home to roost
with the rest of the marvel cinematic
universe on disney plus
indeed you know we see disney and sony
getting along means we're gonna have
plenty of cool spider-man [ __ ] for years
to come
which is so incredibly important i think
for fans
which is like if you want to marathon
this [ __ ]
if you just want access to this stuff
you know you will now get it
you know right next to the things that
you you you hoped you would get it next
to
um and so this also means that you know
you have all the spider-man movies
including
into the spider verse 2 and spider-man
um
you know far from no they they get they
give a name for it that i can't remember
right now
but spider-man 3 starring tom holland um
you'll get morbius you know which will
also appear on disney plus and
hulu and fx for that matter um all of
the library rights to jumanji and hotel
transylvania and stuff like that is also
part of the deal so
it's great for consumers uh the only
thing missing from the marvel library at
disney plus when this happens
will be the hulk well done
absolutely why because it's universal
together in one place true unless
they make some crazy deal with universal
because who thought they would have made
a crazy deal with sony
that's true man there is precedent where
they're just like here's a bunch of
silly money give us something
yeah or like do we have something you
would like to play with as well
like do you want to cross something over
with a fast and furious universe that
you couldn't have done before
we can help you could you imagine
i mean they're going to space that's
true
soon they'll be if they'll be heading
into the multiverse
i mean there was already a mention of uh
you know when the most recent trailer
broke for fast nine
the that you know one of the
screenwriters was like yeah i i see no
reason why
we couldn't have a crossover with
jurassic world like why not
the only thing we don't have now is
dinosaurs so let's get some dinosaurs
i'm in for sure don't get me to watch
that movie
my [ __ ] dinosaur in it hell yeah what
else we got i'm keeping up the time it's
5 20. mark's got 40 minutes
excellent um vin diesel is making
a rockin sock'em robots movie
yes i heard about this i was speaking
about it with ralph garman earlier this
week
um hollywood babylon or give me
headlines the
podcast we do at that kevin smith club i
forget where which one i think the
latter however that all being said
this sounds an awful lot like real steel
doesn't it
it does which if you've never seen real
steel
wonderful movie it's great really hugh
jackman is
magical this relationship drama between
father and son is really sweet
and the robot stuff is is endearing it's
a really cool movie
like i did not expect to be as affected
by it as i was
agreed i remember watching the trailer
and being like come on but the movie
itself is quite cute
and i remember seeing the trailer and
being like this is rock'em sock'em
robots the movie and apparently
so did vin diesel because now he's doing
it yeah
i want to do that for myself now can i
have one um
i mean look it's it's being made by
mattel
you know which is a parent company to to
uh
the good folks that pay our bills for
the last year um
so i'm all for it but that being said
i'm like
this sounds exactly like real steel like
maybe
you might want to alter the story like i
don't know that you should do
father-son story that that's very real
steel
yeah i mean it's it's it's so unclear
what the hell this is going to be
you know because even weirder is he said
it's the party's universe building world
building
so i told ralph on the show i was like
you know that means [ __ ] it's next
first they do rock em sock em robots
then rock em sock em robots versus
hungry hungry hippos
then sock'em robots verse
in the mouse trap nice
all the games then rock em sock em
robots down the chutes and ladders
rock em sock em robots versus barbie
rock of soccer robot versus simon's
rock'em sock'em robot
colon simon says where he literally
battles simon
was an old game that had colors that you
had to press
yes it was it was like boop beep boop
boop boop and then you just press the
button as it lights up
and then it gets more difficult and you
have to continue the pattern until it
yells at you from messing it up
imagine how difficult it would be if you
don't have fingers but only
fists to punch the buttons sock em
robots
oh my my my um so yeah that's happening
well you know what i remember i even
said to ralph
i remember when they announced the lego
movie and i was like are you [ __ ]
nuts and they made that
one of the greatest motion pictures ever
[ __ ] devised so
who knows maybe vin diesel's on to
something that that we can't
see maybe this is his chance to be
superb
[Music]
yes that is the rocking second robot we
got and i'm happy about it
he's got a history of it all right what
other news uh last news story
is that dear white people writer
director justin simeon
is moving into disney's haunted mansion
and he will write and direct an
adaptation
um of the theme park attraction
uh second the second uh
haunted mansion project indeed in 2003
there was an eddie murphy movie
yeah yeah um
well are they gonna tell the you know
what
i was gonna i was gonna start listing
all my haunted mansion
knowledge from working on kingdom
keepers and [ __ ] that'll just sound like
sour
good for him that's awesome they got a
[ __ ] uh
uh jungle crew no what's the show
they're doing jungle cruise
well that's a movie what's the movie
with the rock what are they doing with
uh
what the [ __ ] and star trek dude uh ron
moore
they're they're you know it's it's very
sort of at this point
um secretive and it's like a different
club or something right it's the society
of explorers and adventurers
which is not part of the jungle cruise
that's part of like basically the entire
magic kingdom
you know that will touch on all the
lands and tell some other story that's
inside all of it
um i don't know if jungle cruise is part
of it if i had to guess probably not
only because they've got the movie
coming out but um but yeah
disney is going to exploit everything
that is exploitable
i mean wisely so a couple years ago
somebody was like hey let's make a
pirate movie out of our pirate ride and
they [ __ ] made a couple shekels off
of that so yes like five billion dollars
later
like we should do more of this shouldn't
we expect within five years
churro the movie everyone's favorite
part of disneyland or
giant turkey leg the movie
or dole pineapple whip
see now there you go now you're talking
i mean [ __ ] these these are the reasons
to go to [ __ ] disneyland for heaven's
sakes club 33 the movie yeah that'd be
amazing i'd watch that they should do a
whole [ __ ] show called club 33
where nothing good goes on after dark
and [ __ ] like that
with all the stories about walt that are
questionable and [ __ ]
it was a playboy penthouse when like
yeah would just like
have a bunch of people come over and
like hey there's dick gregory telling
jokes and there's lena horn singing a
song and here's
f no man nobody's singing a song or
[ __ ]
telling jokes they're all [ __ ] and
watching
walt just sits there with a tall boy
[ __ ] watching
all of old hollywood [ __ ] and he's like
it's like hey uh
um do me a favor draw that from my eyes
hey wish upon that star am i right
[Laughter]
that's why i can't get a disney series
because of [ __ ] like that
stop tempting me into that behavior mark
i'm sorry i'm i'm the gateway drug
you really are um all right that's all
the news we got that's the news my
friend
anybody else got any news in chat that
you feel like we missed and [ __ ] i think
mark
probably hit it all but i feel like uh
if there's anybody got something to say
bamf oh dear ladies and gentlemen
heavens it's our own little night
crawler himself jc how are you
bamf boy good uh people on twitter were
saying jc
is a banff badass [ __ ] and i was
like oh it's so clever
that's good um a lot of people are
asking about mortal kombat but none of
us have seen mortal kombat right
that's why we're not talking about it i
have not watched me and mark were
talking right before
the show started uh mark didn't watch it
yet either so that seems like something
we'll get to
uh next week i am way caught up on
invincible and just to give you all a
tease
for next week just to work your nipples
a little bit
um the great robert kirkman the richest
[ __ ] we've ever known
billionaire robert kirkman is uh coming
back on the show
to talk about invincible season finale
which airs
next friday they just put up you know uh
yesterday
the uh episode whatever it is second to
last but
uh next one ends the the season
um and that show has been [ __ ]
fantastic
so we're going to talk to him about that
uh next week
yeah there is one last news story um
it's it's not quite on brand um except
that it totally is
jim steinman passed away um the great
rock
power balladeer himself um the man who
wrote
like every great meat love song every
great every great song that feels
too big for this world is the thing that
sort of came from his pen
um including two of the greatest songs
that ever been put on the soundtrack
the soundtrack for streets of fire
that's right he's responsible for
writing those songs that's why they're
so
operatic and huge and i don't know
how i ever got the bright idea that i
was cool alone and independent
and i'm depending on you now and you'll
always be
the only thing that i just can't be
without
and i'm out for you tonight i'm coming
out for you
today take it mark even
do that [ __ ] um those songs of course
uh he would do anything for love but he
won't do that
right which we're all pretty sure was
about kind of like
i thought it was pegging is that what it
is i'll do anything for love but i won't
take an
ass i gotta re-listen to the song
through that
yeah i guess it works you're right about
that
um he also of course wrote about out of
hell
meatloaf's album with uh i want you
i need you but there ain't no
way i'm ever gonna
love you now don't be sad
don't be zagre two out of three
ain't bad and then of course what's the
big famous song paradise by the
dashboard light yeah
and he also wrote total eclipse of the
heart right yeah for that with for
bonnie tyler bonnie tyler all those
songs are just so
[ __ ] big man like just
thunderous lyrics huge orchestrations
like all of them seem like they're from
a [ __ ] broadway show
but a big broadway show yeah he was a
magician how old was this guy
uh he was in his 70s um i don't have the
exact age
he deserved to live forever i mean he
will through his [ __ ] work that's for
sure but like
[ __ ] man a guy that talented can't
[ __ ]
he died too young you know who else died
too [ __ ] young shock g
yeah digital underground the humpty
dance humpty hump himself man
57. that is too goddamn young way too
young
i mean aside from digital underground he
worked with a bunch of people and stuff
but yeah
then my favorite tweet about that was
that um in honor of shakti's passing all
the burger king bathrooms are now closed
kids may not know this but he once got
busy in a burger king bathroom
he did one of the greatest [ __ ]
lyrics ever written in a song
because with one lyric it tells an
entire story that the song's not about
that you're like
can we hear that once got busy in the
bringing
tell me that one um yes yeah that's a
huge loss as well two big losses this
week
to the world of music ma'am um they're
pointing out oh man
boys back ladies and gentlemen is that
where you
got the idea to have silent bob
in the movies bathroom in
was i should have yes but no
i should have just been like [ __ ] yeah
man that's an honor of shock g but i
can't lie i love them too
um no no but there was uh
i was you know i was just gonna tell a
story but no
i once got busy but not in a burger king
bathroom it was in a
crowser's bathroom let's just leave it
there ooh
crowsers i know right
chat's also hollering russell crowe
apparently said he was going to play
zeus in thor he spoiled his role
in uh thor loving thunder
uh russell crowe who's in the movie is
going to be playing
zeus he said here for it
i i do like me some russell crowe uh dmx
was laid to rest
yeah um
he uh he i mean aside from being
a genius rapper he uh gave the world a
song
that i borrowed and stuck in zakamir
make a porno
perhaps it's one of his most famous
tracks or at least most popular
y'all going to make me lose my mind
um okay that's all news it's all the
news
there's the news kids you got all the
news that's fit to print that means we
got time to do
some questions by the power of grayskull
you have the questions i wonder if we
could check in on our hi-ho
um
is back ladies and gentlemen you got
news first in ohio they
are working on getting me the hi-ho
video right now
so i think it'll probably come after
news or sorry after q a
excellent kids if you haven't had a
chance go over to download the hi-ho app
and uh answer this week's question
about your favorite moment from captain
america
and the winter soldier aka falcon in the
winter soldier
spoiler uncle sam and uncle buck
um and we'll be collecting them and
putting them on the show later on after
we are done with the news so you're
talking about after sorry after q
a i still have to they have to send it
to me i have to download it and queue it
up so
uh i'm so i said q a because i was about
to say after the three wishes
that was a part of the show could you
imagine like it would be as if the show
took place in that netflix movie where
half the world was like
fairies and [ __ ] like that will smith
was in it remember
bright yes right which was kind of like
onward but without the cartoon yeah and
also like not good
yeah that would be weird man if we were
just around [ __ ]
magical and [ __ ] i also wanted to
shout out will wilkins pointed out that
in the montage at the end of falcon and
winter soldier when they're
showing corn getting boiled and and uh
sam
taking pictures with everybody and
eating crawdad or
cooking crawdad you're asking about it
in every single photo
he takes he's on their left
who's will fountain will pick that up
yeah
you think that's intentional um
hopefully we'll get a chance to ask
malcolm spellman
yeah man what the hell hey marvel
remember we you know
we're good give us give us some people
to talk to
we treated your matt shackman really
nice yeah man we want to talk to
malcolm spellman now um but uh
but you know even if we don't get to
talk to him hats off they did such a
great job on that show
um okay give us a question jc
um well we didn't see mortal kombat
but um i have kind of a crossover
question from orange 2591
if you could take a character from
marvel and put them
into the mortal kombat tournament who
would you choose
i'm ticking any marvel character and i'm
sticking them into the ben
cobb do they have that song in the movie
i
you know if i had to guess yes they do
better right
i don't want a remix it has to be the
old classic
that makes me want to go to a roller
rink
shirt like prince and a bunch of like
little bandoliers wear a puffy white
shirt like [ __ ]
captain america there you go
said something about that because i
couldn't put my finger on him like
he looks doughy and i know he's not
snowy like
it's the outfit it's the white nobody
should be wearing that much white
white yeah white is not it's not a good
look it reminds me a lot of like
the original cap outfit from the
avengers where you're like that doesn't
look that good
like the colors are on point but it
looks uh
stuffed in there sausage casing that's
not quite
it um all right marvel character that i
want to stick into the tournament
into the mortal kombat tournament
juggernaut nice
thank you fight him fighting gore [ __ ]
it man [ __ ]
it um i i thor
i think i think mjolnir is a good mortal
combat weapon
um it's the opposite of get over here
yeah
just stay there like get over there yeah
well yeah just lots of lots of [ __ ]
hammer work and you do the spinny like
shield when guys are trying to punch you
and then lightning strikes
all that seems like it's very cool i
like it
all right there you go that's one yeah
done
bamf in here yeah there he is um saying
the thing that made him world famous
[Laughter]
um the next one and i'll use it to plug
something i'm doing
uh when we had christian on a couple
weeks ago
a lot of people in chat were like jc
should get on schmodown he'd do pretty
good
and i'm doing uh star wars
trivia on schmodown on may 4th on may
the 4th
may the 4th day for star wars fans so 3
p.m
on the shmo down twitch channel you can
watch me do star wars trivia
um boy oh boy you're going to have a
blast
you'll [ __ ] win though man you know a
lot i'm not
my my weak point what's his uh [ __ ]
what's that fucker's name against sam
whitwer
[ __ ] you and whitby man like i always
thought i was a star wars fan until i
had conversations with you guys and i
was like i've bend a knee
i'm not your cr i gotta stay away from
the sequel trilogy i don't know that as
well i'm giving away my weakness on the
show but
yeah don't [ __ ] come on man they pay
attention to that i'm gonna study up
all you have to do is re-watch them once
but the uh
so the question that's gonna be hard for
you so hard for you but you gotta do it
yeah toothpicks there
um really well little brother uh games
unhinged
uh was asking uh because schmodown is
kind of like wwe meets movie trivia
was asking uh what song would you walk
out to if you were a wwe wrestler
and what would your gimmick be
my i would walk out well my gimmick
as a wwe or an aew wrestler
would be um
the silent but deadly
my character would be blunt man
my song that i'd come out to
um would be
smoke some kill by school e.d
is incredibly specific but i appreciate
it
i was just thank you for breaking the
silence because i really held the moment
i was like
schooly d like i [ __ ] threw down
there yeah obviously i've given this
some thought ladies and gentlemen
uh i have not given it any thought so
let's just roll off the dome uh
uh maybe i i am still one of my favorite
moments
in any filmed ring entertainment is
um when uh
the the the numerous names and sober k's
that are given to apollo
creed when he enters the rock and my
favorite one of them
is the count of montefisto um so i feel
like that becomes my ring name i'm the
count of money fisto
um i i kind of want to enter
to uh britney spears hit me one more
time
that feels on brand um and i don't
really know what my gimmick is
um uh yeah i'm i'm at a loss
unless it's some super cool [ __ ] move
what's your name
counter monty fisto count of manifesto
um you're a lot are you mark bernardin
battling
mark bernardin sure so that you so
people know your
history so your history is the
um oh oh
oh i got it ready yes your power move
your signature move is called the
writer's block
it's how you've taken down all of your
biggest opponents and it's how you won
summerslam you know 2018 that year
when you busted the writer's block the
impenetrable defense that is the
writer's block
yes it's a trap move some people think
it's boring wrestling but it [ __ ]
you won the title that's all it counts
yeah and instead of like the cool
eyebrow because i can't do that
there's just a lot of this
oh look at he's just like what was the
no
and then your [ __ ] catchphrase in the
ring
is uh i'll allow it
right that's when i drop the writer's
block and invite him in and then i do
the finishing move
i'll allow it or when he hits when you
get hit with a move
and you shake it off and you're like
i'll allow it everyone's like
hit me baby one more time i don't know
why i suddenly have like the iron chic
accent but i feel like that's the
coolest version of that
chefs jeff's kiss my friend ooh
see now who's finishing movies jeff's
kiss
that's true that's our tag team yeah
when you play tag team our finishing
move is the jeff's kiss they're like
here he comes he's taking him off the
top buckle oh here comes the
jeff's kiss they did it again ladies and
gentlemen that that's when you and i
jump from opposite sides of the ring
and our heads like literally butt the
dude in the middle
bam ooh he's followed by that jeff's
kiss
we couldn't see it coming they did they
closed with yet another jeff's kiss
after a while people are like move on
[Music]
it's boring yeah start to do something
else so like what the [ __ ]
it's our signature move um all right jc
come on back bamf
um
it's just the perfect amount of passion
it's the passion of a waffle house
waitress at two o'clock in the morning
what do you want ghostbusters what do
you want
okay uh last question and we may have to
fill some time because we're
i'm still waiting on the render of the
the hot the hi-ho but um
king bishop wanted to know
uh and says uh looks like sharon just
went from wanting
an army of captain americas to an army
of iron men
which would you rather have and why
do i want an army of super soldiers or
an army of iron warriors
um well i'll take the suits
because you know you put somebody in the
suit
you could you know conceivably they
could be on
your side you know what i'm saying
before they get in the suit super
soldier
once they got the shot you got to
[ __ ] be super sweet to them all the
time because they could just
like hissy fit out on you and rip you in
half and [ __ ]
so yeah i'd be tougher with the super
soldiers can't
can't count on them like you know as
zemo pointed out only
there was only one steve rogers so i
would go with an iron
legion um you know that i would
that could hand pick the people that go
in the suits and [ __ ] like mark would
get one
jc would get one you know [ __ ] i could
trust these people
i don't know if they could drive the
suit that's up to them but the [ __ ]
their morals are strong enough where i'm
like here you could take a look at this
[ __ ]
you know weapons technology and [ __ ] but
super soldier
yeah you gotta change someone's dna and
all that [ __ ]
and [ __ ] who wants to play god not me
the only time i play god is when i'm
[ __ ] writing
and uh you know coming up with wrestling
moves like the writer's block
that's that's my god that's mine that's
my god mode
um did that answer the question yes i
did
mark you yeah i i think i i concur
because i think ultimately you are
granting a lot of power
if you're giving somebody the super
soldier serum and you cannot
count on that person to remain you know
loyal all the time because suddenly they
have
you know the power of a tiny demigod
whereas
you can always shut down whatever super
suit you give somebody
um you can replace the person in that
suit if you need to
um you remain in control
and i think if you're looking to build
an army the most important part is the
command and control part of it you have
to
be able to command them and you have to
have control over them and if you don't
then you're just aching for betrayal
so yes i go suits too two suits
two suits ladies we'll take two suits to
go
i'm seeing uh some people are reporting
that uh hijo
is down or giving him trouble or some
traffic at this point and stuff
um but uh feel free to get your answers
in any time you want kids but
uh i believe they've pulled their uh
best for the night that jc is wrapping
up
to show us in a little bit so bam means
i i have it do we want to we want to
roll it oh you guys won't be able to
you can see it but you won't be able to
hear it so when i start
playing it turn on the youtube
volume clever i'll mute it on zoom and
then i'll turn it on youtube and be able
to watch it
perfect and um oh this is have you seen
it jc
i've not seen it we're gonna go into
this blind
see how i don't think so kids early at
the top of the show
we sent you over to the hi-ho app to uh
and we posed i posed a question up there
and the question was what's your
favorite moment
from uh falcon and the winter soldier
and so uh the good folks at hijo pulled
some of the best answers uh for us to
show you here
so uh check it out jc let's run it
what's your favorite moment from falcon
and the winter soldier let me hear it i
loved
isaiah bradley at the end in the museum
emotional and and
great acting but mostly because you guys
called it last week
when mark was spot on with the doctor
who analogy from last week
and sam took isaiah and
his nephew to the smithsonian museum and
there was the statue of him and the
picture of the real soldiers from world
war
ii and of the
black soldiers that were there fighting
in their regiment and everything i was
crying it was one of the best moments
and i was so excited that mark had
called it easily
all the sam stuff the costume reveal his
speech against all the governors
and all that [ __ ] was awesome um and
isaiah getting to see it on tv
oh my god and then the memorial at the
end that
i bought like a baby has to be giving
isaiah bradley
his um his own memorial at the
smithsonian
i really liked that they paid it off um
not to get critical i don't feel like
they paid off
the bucky storyline an equal kind you
know falcon brought isaiah to
the museum that was touching
we'll be lying
john walker um the shield with the blood
on it just
such a visceral image and such a badass
moment for the mcu
and uh just give me chills when the
falcon
shows up in the captain america outfit
and all his glory i was gonna say
double agent carter but it has to be
when anthony mackie shows up with the
captain america suit
absolutely when sam brought uh isaiah
and elijah
to the museum to show the monument and
actually pausing to read to see that
it actually showed the tragedy of the
story as well uh yeah
love y'all take care the julia louis
dreyfus reveal
because i think it's amazing when the
mcu brings in actors who you never
expect to see in the in the mcu
especially actors
known for comedy julia reed dreyfus paul
rudd
people like that i thought the best part
was when they brought isaiah bradley to
the
updated captain america memorial at the
museum
and showed him that uh he was not
forgotten the moment that had my jaw
drop on the floor john walker ripping
off the wings
of falcon just a clean break on both
ends i mean that had some impact
i'm honestly surprised that moment
wasn't in any prior movies my favorite
moment were sam's words
no super serum no blonde hair no blue
eyes
the only power i have is that i believe
that we can do better
as a person without blond hair and blue
eyes that resonated with me
isaiah his performance the first time
they went to see him
it was incredible i mean so much emotion
yeah that guy is a pretty damn good
actor
the end of episode six where the title
changes to captain america
and the winter soldier which is followed
by the big announcement that captain
america four
is in the works the therapy definitely
the therapy scene
bring that old dude to to that museum to
show him that
here you go with your heritage everybody
will know that [ __ ] that's that's the
best thing when captain america
confronts the grc and tells them about
themselves that's my favorite part oh
man there's so many great moments in
that show
the finale episode had i think the
majority of them to be honest
how to choose i'm just gonna say yes yes
look at that man it was great that was
dope
hi ho hi
that was awesome thanks to the good
folks at io
uh for uh their app and for putting that
together
for us to put that there that that's
just something i think we should keep
doing on the show man that's not to see
people like everyone else weighing in
and [ __ ] like that and all of them had
good points
the one dude who's talking about like uh
falcon going like my only superpower is
we could do better
such a great moment um yeah that's
that's sweet man
and i appreciated you know the couple of
dudes who uh you know pulled
deeper into the show like the one guy
was like yeah the the bloody shield
was his like yeah [ __ ] i almost forgot
about that like
did you get to read the uh somebody
asked here in the chat
uh maurico gray says have you read the
isaiah bradley memorial i froze it
before he walks into the frame
so i could read it and i read the first
three paragraphs but i couldn't see the
the bottom paragraph yeah i couldn't
read it either
but uh it's good stuff it basically
tells the story as we know it
um well [ __ ] man
bam fun in here bamf boy
bam bam boy is back ladies and gentlemen
did you have a good time
did you have a [ __ ] how good of a
time was it a skeletor
shogun warrior a good time
with his own [ __ ] havoc staff um
i had a blast we gotta get mark out of
here because he's got [ __ ] to do ladies
and gentlemen
but uh boy oh boy that was a packed show
uh we did a lot we did a lot in so
little time
we get we get a lot done when we don't
have to deal with [ __ ] guests
uh you enjoy that [ __ ] kids if you
enjoyed it
because the gentlemen you see on the
screen uh that aren't me
uh jc he's the one to make sure that we
get to you uh via the stream and uh
there ain't no show without that guy
down there mr mark bernardin ladies and
gentlemen
yeah thank you sir and that there kids
i'm repping my boys gear oh [ __ ] you got
your hundreds yeah man thank you to
everybody who
sold out the hundreds line of gear uh
that uh bobby
and ben dropped the other day on 4 20
the night you know on
4 19 at midnight east coast time 4
20 midnight east coast time um ship went
on sale 36 hours later the whole line
was sold out
so thank you you made me feel very young
kids
um that was fun and some great pieces
where you you bought one online
i did man i [ __ ] like once i found
out once i heard word like i got to get
me some merch
merch i know a guy i could have hooked
you up you know honestly
i thankfully from the photo shoot we did
i walked with a movie shirt and a pair
of kevin smith jorts because
that [ __ ] went it's [ __ ] gone it's
like i'm wearing them i'm wearing them
home
um this week ladies and gentlemen is the
the uh
jay and sam bob's crypto studio opens up
uh and we start selling the smoking
tokens
and uh the blunt man and chronic cover
and the kilroy preview nft
and then next month we got the big
kilroy
auction you know uh for the the rights
to kill roy was here
um as an nft um you we're on fantasma
chain so if you're interested
in that sort of thing go join over on
fantasy and get your
your ecto wallet and get ready to dive
into the fun
there are five uh total of ten
platinum smoking tokens uh five will be
in this first drop
and then five in the second drop uh if
you win one of those
bam you're in clerks three which we're
supposed to be shooting this summer
so if you're into some people like oh
crypto you're killing the planet
uh phantasma chain is doesn't do that
where actually it doesn't work on ether
it works on seoul so it doesn't take
nearly as much mining or as much energy
it's the most ecologically
uh friendly nft platform there is you
could read up on it and stuff
uh but if you're into that sort of thing
come join me uh
april 28th we open the doors of jay and
salam bob's crypto
studio uh what about you and your shirt
my friend where can they get your shirt
not that shirt but your other shirt my
other shirts you can go to embattled
clothing e-m-b-a-t-t-l-e-d
clothing dot com use the code mark 15
say 15
off your offer your order um
yeah man get yourself some merch merch
it up merch merch merch it up
mark 15 should be the name of the comic
book series you do about yourself
that's your wrestler name mark 15.
the mind of a 15 year old the body of a
50 year old
um we will be back next week kids
probably saturday does that feel right
to everybody
i think it feels right it'll give us
some time to watch the finale of
invincible before having monsieur
robert mann on the program billionaire
uh mark billionaire
robert kirkman will be joining me and
mark uh
next week um billionaire playboy
philanthropist
um robert kirkman do you want to see
what real
pure money looks like tune in next week
and you'll watch it
money will talk to you and that money's
name
robert kirkman um we'll talk about uh
the amazing invincible which you if you
have not
given time to yet it is so worth your
[ __ ] time
my god it is so [ __ ] good and it's
coming to a
huge crescendo in this next episode the
season finale so
watch that come on back and join us and
we join uh
as we're joined by the very funny always
[ __ ] low-key
like you know nobody expects the spanish
inquisition
and they don't expect how [ __ ] funny
kirkman is man he's
he's so stealth uh come back uh next
week and you you could see us do that
ladies and gentlemen no more
falcon in the winter soldier to watch uh
and talk about next week we got a month
down before we dive into loki land and
stuff
i know but luckily we'll hopefully knock
on wood
be back in the cantina in a couple of
weeks and so
the the what we will lose in the weekly
recap we can maybe gain
back in the in-person experience and you
know what we'll be able to get a weekly
recap going
with uh bad batch because banff boy
loves that [ __ ]
i have a couple people who've seen it uh
who haven't told me anything but say
it's amazing
it's really really really great
um they're sending i think i heard
they're sending us you know those
like invincible sent to pre preview box
or whatever i think we're getting a bad
batch box as well so we might be able to
crack that open uh next week or whenever
we get it and stuff but yeah during the
run of the bad batch you you'll
definitely see bam boy popping in and
out and talking about it man because
that's his
he [ __ ] this this kid [ __ ] loves
extended universe like you read about
oh my god it ain't good enough to just
enjoy
the great movies they give us he's got
to know
all that [ __ ] games books
side characters that are only now
becoming popular to
the mainstream so you know bad batch is
so right up
jc's crack i'm sure we'll be able to do
every episode
um with them and then uh we'll be back
to some loki
thank you and then we got some black
widow
oh
there it is kids thanks for hanging out
mark's gotta get out of here we're gonna
get out of here
for fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernardi
tune in next week same fat time same
fat channels spodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss
you